We need to be careful cuz a lot of
people also go to scholars in different
lands as well and they're not aware of
what's the going in the western world
and they give fat that causes har but
you don't know the affairs of do you I'm
trying to say listen let me say people
that do and they will not reach him in
his in his knowledge and let's face that
and he's a great he's a great service to
the um
I am a reaver and I was taught how to
pray salah that means every single time
I pray the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from fud to if
you want to support someone like me in
learning salah, then sponsor 10 people
for just £100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate now.
So guys, before the video, as you guys
know, today could be the 27th night
inshallah. Not could be, it is the 27th
night, but we don't it can in do not
miss this opportunity. Brothers and
sisters, we're a charity that's printing
50,000 of these guided prayer masks in
uh Italian, German, French, Spanish,
Portuguese, Albanian, and English,
inshallah. And we're going to be
distributing them to da tables, mosques,
prisons, ISOs all over UK, Europe, and
Latin America. We've got onetoone salah
instructors. We're opening salah hubs
all across UK, Europe, and even Latin
America where people will learn how to
pray salah, brothers and sisters, and
we've got an app that's coming out. You
want to do a you've done water wheels,
you've done masjid, you've done
orphanages, add this to your list. You
know why? Because this is something that
can outlive a water well. A person who
learns how to do wudoo learns how to
pray salah learns the Quran fat and live
for 20 30 40 50 60 years you will get
the for them teaching their kids every
time they do woo. Every time they pray
and every time they recite brother and
sisters donate inshallah. Let's get on
with the video. Asalamaikum guys hope
you guys are well inshallah. We are in
Mecca and the haram brother sisters.
Today is potentially the 27th night. Um,
I'm not saying it's guaranteeing, but do
not miss this opportunity.
So, we wanted to do this video because I
didn't really want to touch upon this.
Even the first video, I didn't want to
get involved because I don't want people
to have the assumption that cuz, you
know, she had a specific ruling, an
opinion on the show that I was doing.
So, I didn't want it to come across as
if it's a personal matter and I talking
off by the
which we're talking about.
Okay. Allah preserve it. Amen. I mean,
so I didn't want it to come across as if
I'm trying to have a go at because he's
my elder and he had the opinion and I
totally respect his opinion. So I tried
to abstain from the video. But when I
saw the enemies of Islam using it, I
spoke to we did a bit of spoke with the
brother spoke to Sneo for let's do it in
a way where the sheh answer the question
and I'm just there with a little bit of
nia. Now there's a lot of people
attacking the sheh etc. which I believe
it's it's not right. There has to be
when it comes to these things. It's a
mistake. It's understandable. Yes, it
was distasteful. Yes, the enemies of
Islam used it against Islam. they're
going to do it anyways. Um, but one
thing I wanted to point out where I
believe it's not the chef's fault in
what angle. And again, I want to be
careful with this cuz I don't I don't
want people to make it feel make it look
like I'm being sneaky by saying this cuz
I genuinely was assessing thinking, can
we blame the sheh? Of course, there
could be some blame. But I was thinking,
and correct me if I'm wrong, the the
sheh from what I know, the little I
know, he lives in Muslim lands. He's in
an Islamic environment. If I was to live
in these lands all my life, if you came
and said to me women do this or men do
this and I will say I want to be if I
was told that there are people who come
and say uh argument sake
um this hadith or that hadith or some
people say you know what oh I'm a little
bit doubtful I'll be shocked because you
need to understand it's like living in a
bubble not intentionally but you're
living in Islamic lands where everyone
the woman cover up the men cover up as
well you know the outrage as well
whatever it There is hay, there is
modesty, there is Islam, there is salah.
The the tradition or the tradition the
people is totally different. So I
believe that maybe that you know subhan
Allah to go and expect the sheh to have
that cuz you need to understand da'ah is
not the same as an alim's job. An alim
can do da we cannot do what they're
doing. However, in certain aspects like
let's suppose I'll give an example like
for example, let's say there's an alam.
I would say an alam who comes to the UK
and let's suppose he speaks perfect
English. I believe he still would not be
fit for the job not because of his lack
of knowledge cuz his is knowledge is a
mountain. However to understand the
western world the of the people and we
know Imam Malik if I'm not mistaken
would was people came from different
lands to ask him questions and he would
say go to your lands and ask the
scholars of your lands cuz they know
your affairs the best. I don't know if
it was Malik, but one of the answers.
No, no. I I'll give you a
contemporaranian. A
contemporaranian. It was asked by
someone. I believe he was an Egyptian
who asked him a question regarding he
said, "Where are you from?" He goes,
"From Egypt, I believe." He said, "Go
back and ask the uh followers of your
land." Yeah. And this that was that was
the that was the answer. Exactly. to
expect for example cuz the sheh doesn't
know like reverts their struggles in the
western world what they faced with the
shabbah that they have etc that's the
reason the way the she gives the answer
and maybe because that's his style where
he's very to the point cut and that
doesn't it requires sometimes hekma you
know so the thing is I believe the sheh
is not at fault maybe that question
should have not been asked to him but
the point is that we need to understand
guys with this kind of stuff you will
see some brothers for example that are
not as knowledgeable but when it comes
to the daer you can see he knows what
he's doing cuz experience in the field.
Look the the sheh is a seeker of
knowledge. Yes. Is a sheh is a seeker of
knowledge. Yeah. He was asked the
question. He asked by that which came to
his mind and I'm sure that he would have
asked according to the rules of the shah
he wouldn't have stepped out the sh. He
would not have stepped out the sh
because we don't expect him to do so. We
don't expect him to do so. Someone of
his caliber wouldn't do it.
And uh you know and even if even let's
say even if it was even if he was like
outside of that we should do it's not
done. Yes, we should do maybe that was
uh slight mistake from him a
misunderstanding something like that we
can experience as well in a sense the
dealing with the western people it's a
whole different ball game it's not he's
not blame worthy of that he's not
exposed to it oh look look it just in
the question the question of uh for
example if we go the question of uh of
uh reeba and lots of things you know now
We in the west
we have everything that we do everything
what we do has got to be transactions
now money hardly we have any money
everything is with cards cards cards
cards and you can't run away like the
pro our banks there's hardly any Muslim
banks even the banks that say Muslim
banks are run by the traditional banks I
have got I have got an ama account with
the with a bank and That bank like the
the account I have got is Islamic
account but the bank is a river bank.
Exactly. So like the prophetam said a
time will come the river was so
prevalent the dust dust you the dust
will touch you. Oh wow. Yeah. So in that
aspect brothers and sisters let's just
be careful with that because at the end
of the day when it comes to we know he's
expertise in answering fy questions
fatawa whatever it is you know that he
gets from the other scholars and that's
his area of experience. If someone like
me tried to go in there, I would make
the same um mistake. So I think that's
what happened there. It was just a
inexperience, unintentional experience
of a and it was I think it was and and
it was first time he came across a
YouTuber who was a revert. Do you get
it? So subhan Allah was whatever it is.
But at the end of the day, it goes back
to this. We should not attack the sheh
and make it seem like this. It's it's
like myself going talking about
mechanics. I don't I don't know. I'm not
experiencing that area fully. So I think
that's what it was inshallah. Look, I
mean the look, Subhan Allah, we we in
Europe, we have got the European Council
of Fatwa. Yes. And for example, people
that take uh houses on uh mortgages,
you know, if you go the the kind of the
fatwa that there is, it is allowed. They
allow people to take houses on mortgages
and stuff because every every land has
got I remember like in one of the
fatawis of the Malika of the scholars of
Malika some long time ago where I'm from
and in other places
surrounding they stopped people from
going to Hajj. Wow. Now you're going to
say who can stop people from going to
Hajj? Yeah, exactly. They did stop them
because the reason the route was not
safe. There were bandits. They were
killing people. They were kidnapping
people and that. So it was not safe to
go. So hence a ruling was given to to to
stop it. Just just not long ago there
was a big controversy. The king of
Morocco Yeah. said that this year there
will be no sacrifice. There will be no
no no
no animal sacrifice should take place
this year.
Some scholars of some other lands or
some seekers of knowledge or mash or
they said oh how can he stop this is
from Islam and this and the other. Now
the of that land
you know they are aware of what the
circumstances and that. to each each
like
look sometimes if you ask any now about
the this the cryptos and this uh this
digital currency
you need a specialist to to you need who
knows about economy knows about the the
the how it goes and that otherwise
otherwise any other said no exactly and
that's it guys in a nutshell we need
care of because a lot of people also go
to scholars in different lands as well
and they're not aware of what's the
going in the west and they give fat that
causes harm that no this but you don't
know the affairs of do you I'm trying to
say so it's to be careful inah that's
all I want to say brother inshallah
please inshallah do not attack the sheh
it's just a matter of inexperience and I
don't think it's blame worthy of that
and the has staunch opinions on certain
things that's his style may Allah bless
and preserve him in listen let me say
people that do attack the sheh and they
will not reach him in his in his
knowledge and let's face that and he's
great he's a great service to the um and
and and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said that if he makes his jihad and he
makes a mistake he still has he's
getting reward yes for his mistakes he's
still getting for his jihad yes and if
he if he gets it right he has got two
reward one reward for his jihad and the
other reward for getting it right. So,
so inshallah she is major. So, even if
he's wrong or he's done cuz I don't
think he has got any kind of uh what we
call it uh plans behind it or some
agenda behind it or he got asked that
question. It was surprising to him. He
didn't expect it from someone
and probably he doesn't know the person
who asked him and uh that's it. Yeah.
Guys, may Allah bless and preserve you
guys inshallah. May Allah bless for his
service for the um inshallah. We've seen
nothing but good in him and may Allah
preserve him.